in this scenario right you've got uh
bitcoin which
has a very uh understood simple
framework that is all about uh
provability
uh when it comes to supply um and
ultimately
scarcity right so i can prove to you
that there's 21 million in total bitcoin
that will ever get created
i can prove to you the 18 and you know
million and change
bitcoin have actually uh been issued and
then i can
um i cannot prove to you what the
current
circulating supply is because of the
issues you described
when you then go and you apply those
things to
ethereum i think a lot of people are
asking the question well is this
bad if all of a sudden if you have a
public
transparent ledger with a digital asset
that's supposed to operate on a
decentralized permissionless network
but you can't prove some of those things
is that
not maybe not fatal but is that a red
flag or is that an issue
and i think that's really kind of what
you raised the flag on and we'll say
wait a second
i can't do this why can't i do it or who
has the answer
correct yeah and um
i i think that we're getting close to an
answer um
the latest reconciliation i've seen uh
was
able to if i'm reading it correctly
because frankly they didn't really
format it to where i i don't know if
they're plugging a number or if they
actually
separately calculated this number of
ethereum that have been destroyed
of ether that have been destroyed so um
i think that we're within about 2400
each
of um kind of having the reconciliation
done
um i you know i i kind of found it
this whole thing has been surprising to
me from the beginning because
i thought that this would be pretty
buttoned up that like the
that this wouldn't be an issue because
um you know
it's not impossible what i'm asking for
and it's been interesting to see
uh if prominent ethereum influencers
imply
that i'm asking for something
unreasonable or something that
can't cannot be calculated and i think
they're wrong it can be calculated
they've just never done it before
um and i think that you know it does
speak to
to the ethereum culture and kind of the
the value proposition that they have um
i what i find disappointing is that they
have been
promoting this narrative that eth can
compete with bitcoin as a store of value
and i just fundamentally disagree with
that because
uh of what you you were mentioning um
and
also because of the actions of the
ethereum community right like if
if if if their response to me had been
hey you're right we're fixing this right
now
and it was over in a matter of hours
that would be great
but we're on like day four or five right
now and
we're down to twenty four hundred eath
but you know we're not down to zero
which is kind of
what i look for in an audit is to have
it foot to zero
well and and i think part of this um
because i'm with you right like
you know to clearly state i wrote about
it this morning uh we're recording this
on monday
uh and we're gonna release it the next
day or two but uh when i originally
uh wrote the piece i said look i'm a fan
of ethereum the network like i i
actually believe that it can
empower a whole bunch of things that
bitcoin doesn't empower like it is
solving a different problem and my whole
point is like
ethereum should go double down on what
it's great at and bitcoin should go
double down on what it's
on what it is great at and forget all
the maximalism and tribalism and like
all that nonsense
and so i appreciate i think that you've
got a similar view in that
the one thing that i'll say though is uh
i was
shocked as it sounds like you were at
the
cavalierness and the nonchalantness of
the ethereum community when you ask the
question like to simply ask like hey can
you calculate this
uh to be told we're close enough and it
comes out that you know it's like 300
000
uh ether apart or about 130 140 million
bucks
it's kind of like wait a second like
well i saw somebody tweet i said
if they think that you're close enough
on this well what else are they close
enough on
right and it starts to kind of like you
start to poke a little bit you're like
wait a second there's some smoke here
like
is is there a fire and and not in the
sense of like ethereum's gonna fail
but you just start to get this sense of
like wait there might not be as much
first principles thinking as i
previously thought right there might not
be a sense of urgency like i previously
thought
and so it doesn't necessarily gonna
change you know if you're a hardcore
ethereum or ether believer i don't think
you're going to change your mind over
this but it was surprising and
unexpected in my opinion the reaction
that you got specifically
yeah and and to be clear like i don't
think anyone listening to this should go
out and make
a financial decision based on what i'm
saying
all i'm asking them to do is to do some
some research and to really scratch
under the surface on these assets
and to figure out what i consider to be
kind of like due diligence questions
right of
how many how many exist how how did they
come about existing
how many are going to exist in the
future and you know that's kind of
like corporate governance right you want
to know what the cap table looks like
and you want to know who's authorized to
issue more shares
what is the process around that like
because if you don't do that then you
run the risk of getting diluted out
and you have to be able to protect your
rights right defend your rights as an
investor
and the way you do it with these
decentralized systems is by running a
node
and by running the numbers right adding
it all up of seeing
what percentage of this ledger do i own
uh you know
and and that way you're able to to make
some and
that's where i think it's really
important is to have like the highest
quality information out there
and it was surprising to see like
vitalik point to coin market cap
as uh his trusted
you know data provider for how many eth
exists
um i i think that you know that should
be open source
it should not be a proprietary number
that is only calculated by a select few
of people who work at coin market cap or
who work at another data provider
i think that anyone in the ethereum
community should have
access to the tools for uh
doing the math and figuring out what's
the total supply out there